okay what are we doing here we're doing
panic oh meter on a scale of one to ten
there are uh games being played between
teams that lost
both lost in week one so they are
staring down the barrel of owen two five
games this weekend against teams that
racked up losses right out of the gates
uh we're gonna do one to ten good teams
there uh and and how panicked
should these teams be and let's focus
first on the 49ers who travel to new
jersey for the first of two games at
metlife stadium jets and then the giants
i'm gonna start with them
scale of one to ten
what is the panic level what should it
be right now for your san francisco
49ers you're a funny guy you're a very
funny guy um are they not your san
francisco 49ers well i mean they are
just because of one guy okay but you're
you're right i'm i certainly root for
them there's no doubt about that uh but
i'm a giant fan true blue okay
but either way yeah i'm gonna put it on
the seven there there's there's it's
panic time a little bit
i mean there's injuries throughout the
roster at the wide receiver position for
the 49ers now george kittle's hurt we
don't know what he'll be for sunday or
if he'll play at all and muhammad sunu
is not the muhammad sunu we've known you
know that made a name for themselves in
cincinnati in atlanta with kyle shanahan
there's a reason he'd still be on the
patriots exactly there's a reason the
the patriots cut him with the team that
we question their wide receiving court
so yes like one i know shanahan will
know how to use them and sunu will be
comfortable within the offense but uh
man pass game weapons is certainly a
little bit of a question right now with
in san francisco let alone jimmy
garoppolo as you talked about yesterday
he threw the ball like crap last weekend
and that doesn't make me feel more
confident about them in their passing
game either
and it's amazing there's a 49ers fan
that sent a horribly racist message to
buda baker because he's the one who hit
george kittle and caused the knee injury
and the 49ers issued a statement
yesterday to it an appropriate statement
by the 49ers but garoppolo is the one
who caused it
if you're going to be mad at anybody be
mad at garoppolo he threw the ball too
high on a screen pass
and kittle jumped up for it and got his
knees blown out in the process and we'll
see how bad that knee sprain is and we
saw last year how quickly he can come
back from that kind of an injury but
that that's the problem now next week
when it's 49ers giants
you just said you're a giants fan true
or blue
and you're you're you're your guy kyle's
coming to town what are you what do you
do during that yeah i i root for
shanahan i do yeah i mean it's it's a
personal relationship that's just that's
too special for me as much as i love the
new york giants um yes i i like my buddy
kyle shanahan and his family and they've
been great to me ever since i was 18
years old so uh i am without a doubt
we'll be rooting for them now will i
want the giants to have some success and
like is it one of those things where i
go i hope 49ers like win a close one and
the giants look good too yeah that's
what i kind of hope for in those
matchups but i will be rooting for kyle
and the niners
and i remember last year or the year
before or possibly both we talk about
the stress that begins to creep into a
team after
like owen one like okay forget about it
you get to own two
right
you you you've talked us through this
before so talk me through it again
refresh my memory about how that that
level of anxiety spikes i think it's
after oh and two maybe it's after oh and
three but uh either way it's coming for
some of these teams it definitely is
when you hit owen two you walk into a
building on monday morning after that
second loss
and you start to go whoa i can feel
the anxiousness the anxiety the
intensity in the building already
because now the coaches are
well pissed off on a mission they
realize well we're teetering on the
brink of losing control of the season
and everything like that to where
everything gets tightened up and people
do start to stress out and you start to
see coaches yell about stuff that you're
like what are you yelling at it's not
that's not that to be yelled at
it just it can lose control that way and
only the special teams can overcome it
in my opinion but uh it is a real thing
and i i used to hate it was my worst
thing about being an nfl football player
was when it got to that time of the year
just how uncomfortable and unpleasant a
facility could be when you're in that
situation
and think about it the 49ers should
somehow lose to the jets they're staying
at the greenbrier here in west virginia
in between
games in new jersey and so you throw
that on top of anxiety and the stress
and a lot i
doubt who knows who knows what will
happen but if i doubt the 49ers are
going to lose two in a row to start the
season after going 13 and three i hope
stranger things have happened how about
tom brady panic level for him on a scale
of one to ten after the performance we
saw last weekend i'm not overly panicked
uh are you we got to be realistic i
think we all did a little disservice to
the football gods i'm gonna go like i'm
right down the middle of the road like a
five okay right in that range
you know are there things i i'd like to
see yeah here somewhat soon to believe
in them yes but at the same time it's
brady a new team they're figuring out
how they want to run their offense i
didn't expect it to be perfect week one
or this team to hit the ground running
um
i think bruce aryan's comments add a
little more concern to the situation too
i will say that him publicly calling out
a guy like brady that way that
aggressive and weak one you know i don't
know if i totally agreed with that i
thought that was a little over
aggressive especially the monday
comments about you know hopefully this
week he'll show more grit and
determination i heard yesterday he hopes
more balls go to mike evans to me those
are all shots at brady going mike evans
was open a few times you should have
thrown it you know you should have been
grittier and held in the pocket a little
longer a few times during the game uh
that that is maybe a little more
concerning to me than anything right now
i do think they'll get it together on
the offensive side of the ball
brett favre had a great observation
yesterday on serious xm nfl radio about
the the problem bruce erians may be
walking into by calling out a guy like
tom brady after one game but farf said
there's a chance yes that this is an
agreement it's um
that this is the plan that this is a
twist on bill belichick calling out tom
brady to the team so the other players
know there's no sacred cows this is
doing it publicly so everyone knows
there's no sacred cows there's no
special treatment tom brady's going to
get cussed out just like everyone else
and aryan said that at one point during
camp i'll cuss him out if i have to yeah
and and maybe that's the deal that
they've done if it's not though
you know today's media availability for
tom brady and it's typically wednesday
for the starting quarterback on a sunday
game it's going to be interesting to see
because my guess is somebody's going to
ask him about it
and it'll be interesting to see how he
responds to it and i still think that 20
years of of patriot way will keep him
from saying anything other than he's the
coach and whatever he says he says and i
just go out and play the games but if it
continues
we're going to be watching every week
for some sign of frustration but i'm
with you it's middle of the road panic
right now the schedule softens yeah now
they get the panthers they got to win
this game because then it's house of
horrors time for tom brady back to
denver where he's always struggled but
there are winnable games before they get
the packers week six and and when you
look at their first half schedule
they could get to five and three or six
and two chris yeah they could do it they
got a tough draw right out of the game
no doubt about that and you're right
you'd think they'd win this game this
weekend against carolina
the the broncos chargers bears that's a
good defenses so they will challenge
this football team and that'll make it
tough but yes they're a work in progress
and you know to the bigger point of what
you just brought up that does go on in
football my father would be the first
one to tell you bill parcells there was
a few times through my dad's career
where
bill parcells would tell my dad before
practice like hey i might jump on you
just for something stupid today to kind
of make my point to other guys on the
team and do that so that certainly does
go down
i didn't get that feeling though in the
post-game press conference that it was
like a planned thing i felt like it was
a little bit like oh i'm a little
frustrated because he threw two
interceptions and we didn't win the game
and it just came out of his mouth and
that's where it's different but we'll
see we'll see i know we're we'll be
aware of what goes on here
i agree with you i think this is bruce
aaron's being bruce are you the guy he's
always been the guy who didn't become a
coach until seven years ago because he
won't play the game he won't kiss but he
will say what he thinks and it very well
may be
that when they had that first
conversation whether it happened after
they were allowed to have it or before
they were allowed to have it wink wink
nod nod at some point aryans i'm certain
said to brady hey you gotta understand
how i am i'll call you out you make a
mistake i'll call you out yeah i'll call
out everybody that's the way it is
you're going to if if aryans didn't do
that he made a huge mistake because
brady needs to know going in that he's
not dealing with some head coach who's
going to go out and grumble grumble and
not say anything this coach is going to
go out and say when his guys make
mistakes yeah philip rivers
with the vikings coming to town and the
vikings
anxious to get
to one and one and rivers with two
interceptions in a game that the colts
should have easily won over the jaguars
eight point favorites and they lose by
seven what's the panic level for him
it's this is a weird one uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna say a six here
and it really has nothing to do with the
rest of the football team i mean nothing
i mean you said it they never punted in
the game they moved the ball up and down
the field on the jacksonville jaguars
the offense was great frank reich is
quietly one of the best game planners
there is in all of football i mean every
week when i watch the film i go ooh that
was a cool way to do that or ooh i've
never seen that combination he's always
got something to bring to the table
but
i go six here because
i mean we've just we've seen this story
and i'm concerned that he just can't
help himself he's got to prove to me a
little bit that he can reign it in
and
punt the ball a few times i mean
whatever but when you're in control of
the game you know part of your job as a
quarterback is to realize
how the game is going yeah you go into a
football game all the time going i hope
we go off score 35 and we throw for 350
yards but part of a quarterback's job is
to go oh wait i'm sitting here on the
sidelines it's the end of the first
quarter man their offense can't move the
ball at our defense today man we're kind
of moving at will okay i don't think i
need to take any chances i need to i can
play this conservative i think we're
going to win this game i don't need to
do anything crazy we're the better team
on the field and i just feel like
sometimes that doesn't happen and it's
just throw it throw it aggressive throw
it and it bit them in the butt so
i'm a little concerned just because of
him and it's a habit
and look i take no pleasure in being
right about so far my belief that what
we saw from philip rivers last year was
a harbinger of what we were going to see
this year in indianapolis but i got to
ask this question chris
not many teams have a backup who's
making 15 million a year right in jacobi
yeah what kind of leash does philip
rivers have i i think it's it's it's
going to be
you know
like somewhat long here where he'll get
a a a good four or five games but if
this like continues to be a theme
then yes they're gonna look at a guy and
go okay jacobi at least he won't turn
the ball over at least he won't make
some of these mistakes so it's gonna be
on phillip rivers and hopefully he can
reign it in and play smart football and
not take some of those chances they have
a very good all-around football team
and they should not have blown that game
last week so uh yeah he's got to put
some good games you know together here
to squash that conversation all together
so it doesn't come about halfway through
the year
and even if they lose their home opener
on sunday by the way up to 2500 fans
will be able to attend the game at lucas
oil stadium if they fall to 0-2 they've
got the jets at the bears at the browns
and the bengals before they're by so
there's opportunities to win games and
turn this thing around
and and keep jacobi bracelet on the
sideline remember he was five and two
last year before he suffered the knee
injury that derailed his season because
when he came back i don't think he was
ever the same and then they decided they
got to go out and buy one of these
veteran quarterbacks as a stop gap until
they draft somebody if the stop gap's
not stopping
then you got to go with the guy you have
and you're paying jacob
a lot of money to be available and i
think at some point it becomes a
consideration and and if they lose games
that they look i can say if they lose
games they clearly should have won it
becomes a problem well they've already
lost a game they clearly should have won
so is it the jaguars are a hell of a lot
better than we thought or is it the
cults are a hell of a lot worse that's
why we need three four five games to
really understand where these teams are
the vikings
0-1 giving up more points than they ever
have in any season opener in their
60-year history chris taking it on the
road to indianapolis what's the panic
level for them eight i i think to be
fair i mean yeah i'm a little panicked
about the vikings defense was stinky you
know you said it there's issues there
you know they had schematical issues and
then they had clear like personnel we
can't match up with this guy issue so
that's concerning and then when you flip
it over the offensive side of the ball i
mean we talked about it yesterday i mean
holy crapola
i mean five throws in the first half i
mean you gotta work hard to do that in
this day and age in the nfl so between
that the way the offense looked all the
new pieces
everything to go with it yeah i i'm i'm
uh i think the vikings could be in
trouble and this week is they got to
rebound a little bit and show us what
they're all about
i mean here's the problem when you are
going to jettison as many veteran
defensive backs as they did whether you
cut them or whether you let them walk
away in free agency because you're
confident that you can backfill
if you don't have a pass rush
i don't care who's back there eventually
someone's getting open it could be
charles woodson rod woodson dion sanders
and daryl green in their prime
somebody's eventually getting well maybe
not maybe not with those four but if you
give a quarterback enough time he's
eventually going to find somebody that
he can throw the football to and the
vikings did not unleash a pass rush and
that made it even harder for a bunch of
young corners to up cover devonte adams
and company so i i think it's i think
i think what what it is is it's an eight
and mike zimmer the coach of the vikings
needs to convince them it's lower than
that because i think if they believe it
they're gonna they're gonna press
they're gonna try to do too much
and they're going to walk right into the
trap because philip rivers needs this
game as badly as the vikings defense
does and something's got to break yes
you're right it's a big football game
and the way things looked on sunday i
clearly think the colts are the better
team but phillip rivers is the wild card
in all this are we gonna get you know
the ramblin gamblin could throw four
interceptions at any moment are we gonna
get the guy we saw in the 2018 season
that led his team to a 12-4 record the
second best record in the afc and played
pretty clean football that's what if we
see that the cults could be very
dangerous
i always tend to go with the more recent
he's two years older than he was in 2018
and last year was not good and this year
not off to a good start for the colts or
the vikings or the cowboys lost a game
they could have won maybe should have
won mike mccarthy entering his second
game as coach the team home opener
against the cowboys and they still don't
know how many fans are going to be there
they're allowed to have up to 50 they're
not going to go quite there but they
haven't said how many are going to be
there but there will be fans present
mike mccarthy game two a game they
should win against the falcons what's
his panic level going into this well i'm
not like panicked about
anything in particular that i saw from
the i mean i still think this is a solid
football team they played tough they
were in they were there you know with a
chance to win the football game when it
was all said and done um
so i'm gonna go like a four here
i i am because i'm not like panicked
about mike mccarthy i wish he would have
kicked the field and tied the game and
continued to see if hey can the rams go
down and score and do that you know make
them play
they weren't exactly on fire the rams
offense i mean they just scored 20
points so
i don't understand that still to this
day but you know the other thing i just
want to see again from this offense they
got too many weapons they got just too
many weapons
to
not be doing more on the offensive side
of the ball i wish they would take a
little bit more of a new age approach
mike i think that's if i could say
anything the dallas cowboys and mike
mccarthyis goes like damn you got a you
got two really good running backs one's
a super stud you got three unreal
receivers we got to get the ball in the
hands of these guys more and i just
think there's got to be more
misdirection moving parts you got to
give your guys a schematical advantage
what's the point of having cd lam amari
cooper and michael gallup if you can't
get them the ball and scare people with
it i just wish we would see almost a
little bit more of a kansas city
approach from them you know hey this
amari cooper in the backfield going this
way and cd lamb going that way and it's
a motion there and they stop and they
come back the other way and you know
more screens and more reverses and speed
sweeps and everything like that uh and i
think they can be special that way i
just want to see a little more
creativity from that side of the ball
and just more involvement with all this
talent they have
as part of my newfound effort to emulate
both you and ron jaworski i watched all
of that game yeah
williams and i did a re-watch of it for
pftpm last night
two drives right that stood out at the
end of the first half
when it looked like the cowboys didn't
have enough time to do anything they
sliced and diced and they got down the
field and they scored a touchdown they
took the lead yeah end of the game right
i don't know what the hell they were
doing they got the ball with two minutes
and 28 seconds left and yeah they were
pinned in their own end but it had 228
and they burned off almost all of it to
go 20 yards yeah there was a lot of
passes clearly in bounds no opportunity
to get out of bounds and stop the clock
there was no urgency no creativity they
don't throw the ball down the field the
way they should the one time they did it
was the connection with michael gallup
and i do that more often yeah there's a
lot of balls being sprayed around in
that 15 to 20 yard area at the most
there isn't a whole lot of over-the-top
stuff and you've got guys who can get
down the field and why not do that why
don't i have that threat to make it
easier to do everything else so i was
disappointed i was very disappointed by
their last drive they had more than
enough time to get in field goal range
and then all of a sudden they had no
time and they were in panic mode and uh
that's on both mike mccarthy and the
play caller kellen moore because in that
moment when you still have that window
of opportunity when you still got that
chance to win the game or at least force
overtime and you've got that much i
think they they they got lulled into a
false sense of how much time they had
and before they knew it's like holy crap
we only got 40 seconds left yeah it did
look like that a little bit they were
taking their time and hey look part of
it like again situational football and
things we talk about you know really
good two-minute drill teams too just to
bring up this point not that it was
totally here but like you know if you're
a quarterback and somebody's open for
two yards and you see oh wait he's open
for two yards but he's gonna get tackled
quickly and have no chance to get out of
bounds like tom brady wouldn't throw
that he'd just throw it out of bounds
and go who cares about the two yards we
need the time i'm not going to waste 20
seconds to get two yards and they did
they had some wasted plays there early
on in that drive where you were just
like
ah that wasn't worth it for all the time
you lost on the clock that was stupid
and uh yeah they got to readjust some
things there in dallas yeah well what do
you think if somebody's going to make a
move and they're going to pop free and
they're going to run 80 yards and win
the game it just didn't make any sense
to me to have that lack of urgency when
you still have a chance to win the game
and you're trying to atone for the
misguided decision to go forward on
fourth down with 10 minutes left in the
game when you could have just taken the
field goal tied it up it's 0-0 with 10
minutes left let's go let's see who can
win this game so all right i'm not
overly panicked for the cowboys but
there are
things you know we say all the time
or we hear coaches say all the time we
need to go watch the film and decide
what to fix there are things the coaches
need to fix that they did yeah not
necessarily the players right coming out
of that first game for the cow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports